ça
suite écrit l'équipe enseignante
universitaire en biologie je suis là
aujourd'hui pour partager avec vous mon
expérience et ma vision
ce métier noble qui soit derrière la
révolution et le développement de la
société soit uni derrière sa régression
et son déclin tout le monde voit dans ce
métier là dans le métier de consignes
ans non c'est nous qui est responsable
de
source de quelles sources de la
formation et qui de ce pouvoir de
transmettre ce savoir et de le
transférer à ses étudiants à ses élèves
c'est valable et galère en fait c'est
une relation un peu verticale où
l'étudiant il a appris à collecter de
l'information des données elle est
approuvée le jour de l'examen
et après ils les gardent pas ça c'est
notre affaire
franchement moi le métier de lecture
d'informations demain jamais séduit et
toutefois je respectais et j'adorerais
beaucoup mes professeurs mais je voyais
au fond de moi j'avais une une
conviction que ce métier là il est
beaucoup plus noble
il est beaucoup plus grand bien lui la
tâche elle est très importante de
vecteurs d'information elle est très
très importante mais ça me suffisait pas
au cours de mes quelques années
d'expérience j'ai vu des épreuves qui
ont consolidé mes convictions et qui
m'ont vraiment montrer que je suis en
lieu sûr le droit chemin
mais ceci nécessite obligatoirement on
croit à l'étudiant que c'est à sa
capacité à son application et bien
entendu s'il ne veut pas se faire de la
m
tout le monde donc à partir de là à voir
leurs quelque sorte de enseignement
personnalisé pour que l'on puisse
appliquer cette approche là il faudrait
obligatoire pour appartenir un système
qui permet de sortir du cadre
conventionnel et de tenter une nouvelle
expérience pédagogique une entente
ça nécessite également qu'il y ait des
ingrédients qui doivent obligatoirement
exister s'élance chez l'enseignant le
premier c'est que il aime ce qu'il fait
oubliez le deuxième ces brûlures
n'hésite pas à partager qui viennent ce
qui fait avec ses étudiants parce que
ceux ci comptait gérer le troisième
ingrédient c'est qu' ils soient toujours
prêts soir à subir soit à apporter un
changement au cours de mes quelques
années d'expérience et j'ai vécu trois
expériences en fait est que je voulais
partager
avec vous ces trois expériences là la
première concerne de mes étudiantes
elle était plutôt timide réservé ou ti
et elle appréhende énormément son
passage devant ses camarades de classe
pour sa présentation de peur de ne pas
pouvoir assurer à la fois par rapport à
la langue française que par rapport le
contenu scientifique et c'est là
exactement comme on travaille à la
commencer avec elle ou gelée accompagné
dans sa démarche et dans sa recherche
scientifique et je les ai un peu juste
cadre elle et l'a accompagnée je les
choisis minutieusement parce que c'était
pas d'encadrement est ce que je lui
laissais entièrement la responsabilité
du contenu scientifique mais toutefois
je me montrais les outils pour faire
ceci une fois nous sommes travail est
achevé
je vais les regarder que je me dis
maintenant c'est toi qui connais le plus
sur ce sujet là et tu va nous apprendre
tous et moi la première en lui disant
ceci et je crois que l'apl déclic qui
s'est passé en elle est gelée vu dans
ses yeux une fois elle était le tableau
est là prononcer uniquement et des
qualités à rêver à la partie où l iliade
et ait maîtrisé très très bien elle
s'est carrément déchaînés dans tous les
sens du terme
et là on a assisté à la prestation digne
et d'une soutenance de thèse de doctorat
franchement moi je la contempler les
larmes aux yeux et là je lui dis qu'ils
portent à le dire vraiment j'avais les
larmes aux yeux je crois depuis ce jour
là elle parlera en public sans aucun
problème et je crois même qu'elle prend
du plaisir à le faire
le deuxième exemple heures c'est en fait
ça concerne nous étudiants 7 concernent
leur développement personnel
depuis un certain temps on entre on te
parler de matières qui aide les
étudiants qui ont été introduits dans le
cursus universitaire qu'ils étaient
étudiants à mieux développer leur
personnalité et leur capacité
ça c'est excellent c'est très bien et
bien entendu on parle de softs qu'ils il
était temps pour nous de comprendre que
le diplôme tout seul ne suffit pas et
qu'il faudrait beaucoup plus que ça pour
convaincre dans notre dans l'établé
score où j'exerçais nous avons fini
vous projet une nouvelle idée un nouveau
concept connaît au juste sous culture l
on fait ça consistait à faire ça
consiste à regrouper les étudiants en
simple donc ces cinq étudiants qui
travaillent sur une idée qu'il y toucher
particulièrement ça c'est la première
obligation et qui devraient
obligatoirement lycée à l'impact social
ou culturel dans l'eau à partir de là m6
a amené à travailler sur leurs idées
comme une vraie star tom c'est ce projet
qui devrait être mené en collaboration
avec des ong avec des associations avec
des épaules avec des collèges des lycées
des écoles maternelles
des orphelinats des maisons de retraite
l'année c'est l'écrit très longue et
après ils doivent donner nos résultats
une fruit de leur travail
au cours de cette expérience de la rate
et sont même du second dopantes
ils ont appris à se présenter à négocier
avec des industriels a plenary à une
action à gérer à temps à gérer un budget
à gérer le stress vraiment une enduro de
choses et là je crois que ça doit être
ça les fausses sorties ski moi je suis
pas experte je peux pas l'affirmer mais
ça ressemble fortement
le 3ème ex en fleurs que je vais vous
exposer ce soir c'est en fait ça vous
concerne le personnel et il s'agit en
fait d'une étudiante que dès ses
premiers jours dans l'école
elle a décidé de faire son projet de fin
du qe2 son katana et durant les trois
ans de son recycleur d'ingénieurs elles
étaient toutes total
c'est là jusqu'où quelques jours
seulement avant le début de son père feu
ou la gélatine très lourd de nouvelles
la première de pagnol la plus difficile
à accepter pour moi des moustiques et à
un concert du genre super méchant un
très positif et là tout à fait dans la
dette
tout se fige pendant un certain temps et
[Musique]
des priorités il change carrément et là
on commence à réfléchir sur deux
possibilités tc l'équipe williams l'ex
ça passe on ça passera
une fois la machine à l'oeil est lancé
ça va à très grande vitesse et avec
scanner analyse opération chimiothérapie
pour l'aude et la grille et la liste
elle est très présente
que ce soit donc bien mon dieu comme le
cliché il ya le l'imposent heures c'est
en fait là on commence à réfléchir sur
deux options
c'est que l'on écrit des lettres soit on
enregistre des vidéos
quand les enfants
mais eu vraiment de concept situation
j'avais pas du tout la possibilité de
mener n'importe quel projet encore moins
de cadres et de paix ce vraiment c'était
le dernier de mes soucis et je n'avais
pas la tête à ça du tout jeune étudiante
je me dis je suis désolé je ne pas
honorer mes engagements et je n'ai pas
besoin de cadres et elle l'a dit ok
alors je reste pour septembre le temps
que vous finissez votre avis pour moi
c'était même pas envisageable
je pouvais pas mais elle insiste est
tellement et ils étaient sérieuses en
plus vraiment de nom sans résistance
j'ai accepté c'est tout réfléchi je
savais pas comment faire mais j'avais
accepté
et là je commençais à alterner les cubes
chimiothérapie avec coeur mon travail
dans le laboratoire et j'ai monté très
vite à chaque jour et je les ai su qu on
arrive au 4e étage à la paix j'avais
envie de planter un
si j'avais frappé l'effectif est large
et dès que j'entre dans le laboratoire
je suis complètement emportées par le
travail j'en oublie carrément et j'en
oublie carrément la douleur les soucis
je vis tout simplement la maladie et au
départ franchement je lève je faisais
pourrait éventuellement pour elle mais
petit à petit je me suis rendu compte
que finalement je suis aussi gagnante
est peut-être c'est moi qui la gagnante
est là que ça commence à tourner dans ma
tête
excuse moi il ya des bosses ou qui
sommeille si bon on va dépasser salaires
espoir aussi donc en fait je après avoir
vécu quelques mois avec elle
laboratoire je me suis rendu compte que
j'ai poussé ma barrières physiques gelé
carrément cassé la barrière véhicule et
j'ai compris j'ai mon corps à suivre le
mental
ceci a été réalisé
vraiment grâce à cette étudiante et je
crois qu'à l'art qu'elle va rapporter
quelque chose et je crois vraiment qu
elle a contribué avec un très grande
partie dans ma guérison avec me d'être
un nouveau concept et une nouvelle
quelque chose qu'elle a kel ahaggar tlm
qu'on appelle le travail aux thérapies
ont appelé toutes les deux le travail au
tehran qu'elle m'a imposé avec tellement
d'amour peut-être la plupart d'entre
vous se posent la question mais comment
se fait-il qu'elle parle d'un sujet
aussi vous avec
une telle facilité en fait moi je fais
ça pour deux raisons la première raison
c'est que il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui sont comme moi et qui ont besoin de
voir que on peut dépasser cette maladie
et en plus il suffit d'y croire
il suffit d'avoir le mental qui va à
l'accent ça c'est la première motivation
et je crois que depuis j'essaie de
partager un peu l'information avec les
gens concernés
la deuxième motivation c'est pour rendre
hommage en fait aux personnes qui m'ont
aidé et parmi ses yeux ces gens là d'une
très grande partie ce sont mes étudiants
qui m'ont énormément appris et que m'ont
aidé à dépasser les 7 heures cette
souffrance-là à cette maladie là je
crois peu
à partir du moment où on a vécu à
travers cette année des lames
on doit la considérer comme une
renaissance c'est une deuxième chance et
j'ai vraiment l'intention de la saisir
pour vivre pour enseigner et pour après
autrement je vous remercie infiniment
[Applaudissements]